in most cases their rank-and-file
Republicans are already pro-gay rights
hi I'm Nicolas be with reason TV and
today we're talking with David lamp oh
he's the director of publications at the
Cato Institute and an active member of
the Virginia chapter of the Log Cabin
Republicans and author of the new book a
fundamental freedom why Republicans
conservatives and libertarians should
support gay rights David thanks for
talking to us thank you what are gay
rights as opposed to rights well I think
that's kind of a political shorthand
term just for the idea that gays and
lesbians shouldn't be excluded from the
same rights that everybody else enjoys
and that's why I wrote the book I wanted
a real fact based primer on gay rights
for right-of-center voters even though a
lot are already on board I talked about
that in the book there's a lot of
statistics out there about how they feel
about these issues and in most cases
their rank-and-file Republicans are
already pro-gay rights so then what's
holding them up is it just the
disconnect between the rank and file and
the leaders that's part of it and the
religious right you talk a lot about in
the book right they are a particular
hole on the party they came into the
party beginning back in the 70s when
actually most of angelical voters were
democrats and as they came in and moved
into the party a lot of moderates and
independents left the party why
shouldn't libertarians of gay rights
matter to libertarians why shouldn't
they be in the Democratic Party rather
than kind of chasing after the
Republicans well they have a much more
holistic philosophy a much more Pro
freedom philosophy than just gay rights
if that's the only issue you're
concerned about then I would say the
Democratic Party is the party for you
but gay Republicans are Republican for a
reason that they believe in a variety of
issues limited government free
enterprise that sort of thing and that's
why they're in the party to begin with
so I think our primary goal is to
transform the Republican Party and
actually make it true to its roots of
individual rights and limited government
the libertarians I know tend to be very
much without prejudice or discriminatory
bones in their body but then they get
attacked for saying you know
the same token I don't want laws that
make it difficult for an employer or a
hotelier or somebody to actually have to
work or serve somebody they don't want
to right right well I make the
distinction in the book between public
and private sector discrimination
certainly libertarians all agree about
public sector discrimination and most
agree that public accommodation laws
really run counter to libertarian
principles and so I try to give
arguments on both sides I certainly come
down on the side that the libertarian
side that these laws really shouldn't
exist the fact that they do for a
variety of other groups kind of
complicates the issue though in my view
because if you have a law that covers
public accommodation for example and it
covers a variety of groups that have
historically been discriminated against
and then you exclude by design another
group then you raise new issues of equal
protection of the laws and things like
that so I think it's probably a little
more nuanced a more nuanced issue than
many libertarians I think it is but
certainly my my basic views or
libertarian what do you say should
people who are offended by the CEO of
chick-fil-a you know religious view
should they not by their should they buy
their anyway should they you know what
how do you work through well I'm
boycotts or as American as apple pie and
many groups disenfranchised groups have
used them over the years of the civil
rights movement of course used them and
ironically I think the right wing is a
little disingenuous about this issue
because it's not merely that he spoke
out and and told the public what his
views are on this chick-fil-a puts
millions of dollars into political
campaigns to defeat gate marriage to in
support of proposition 8 that took away
all right a marriage right that already
existed that's really the primary basis
for the boycott I I think it's fine and
it's so odd that conservatives would
complain about a boycott when they issue
boycotts against pro gay organizations
all the time
you have one going against starbucks
Google target and now that amazon has
come out and is going to put a lot of
money into the washington marriage
initiative no doubt their next on the
list as america is getting more
accepting of gay rights or of gay people
is the republican party getting worse
and worse on this issue in most ways the
republican party is changing and the
polling that i mentioned certainly shows
that but there are other things that
that reflect that change Don't Ask Don't
Tell the repeal of that for example
would never have happened without the
votes of eight Republican senators the
passage of same-sex marriage in New York
was made possible again only by the
votes of four state Republican senators
and just earlier this year the New
Hampshire overwhelmingly Republican New
Hampshire legislature voted to keep
same-sex marriage so you see these
changes taking place across the board
okay well David lampo of the Cato
Institute of the Log Cabin Republicans
and the author of a fundamental freedom
y rep why Republicans conservatives and
libertarians should support gay rights
which is out now thanks for talking to
reason TV thank you I'm Nick Gillespie
you